Candid Truth
What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it. First, I want to
start off by um
doing a little introduction on what's
going on this weekend. I got a special
guest in here, my good brother Brad. And
Brad from Strange Normal. If you haven't
ever checked out Strange Normal, go
check out Strange Normal. I'm going to
pull it up right now.
Because uh what do you talk about on
Strange Normal, Brad?
All the strange. Everything that's
strange and that is is a little bit
normal. Actually, we talked primarily
Oh, yeah, there's the intro. Talking a
little bit about uh primarily the the
Strange Normal I call the last day
spiritualism. Something that's happening
that's going to completely change
society and it's going to come and it's
it's all based on the Bible, honestly.
This is this is pretty ridiculous of
what's going to happen and I don't think
normal Christianity is really prepared
for for what's about to break upon the
world.
>> not at all, man. Not at all and and we
get into that a lot. I'm I'm actually a
guest on there a lot. Brad hits me up
and says, "Hey man, you want to come
talk about some aliens and stuff?" And
so we have a lot of fun over there. So
definitely check out You see here we go.
Here's me on that thumbnail, but uh
check out the lives, man. They're really
cool. He's got some really cool like
edited videos that uh
are shorter and more shareable and stuff
like that. And you've been having a lot
of cool guests on lately.
But uh I wanted to talk about what's
happening this weekend. If you guys did
not know about Speeracy-Con, it's the
big convention happening at Cave City,
Kentucky this Friday and Saturday.
Happening this Friday and Saturday, all
day Friday, all day Saturday with a lot
of amazing guest speakers from all
different channels talking about all
kinds of different stuff. There's
actually going to be three stages there.
If you guys never heard of John Pounders
and David Carrico,
uh they're the the main hosts on Now You
See TV on YouTube.
And um
Notice it says more speakers be
announced. So when you click speakers,
you'll see all the speakers. Whoa,
there's a bunch of them. Even Spencer
Smith's going to be out there. It's
going to be cool to get to meet him in
real life. I've talked to him on the
phone before.
Uh there is actually some more speakers
on here. They were on here, but uh
there's more on here including me.
Here's um
let's see the schedule.
Did they
Okay, I was going to say did they redact
their update here?
So here's the schedule.
Um you see they got three stages, main
stage, left stage, right stage. Here's
I'm going to be at 2:30 on Friday.
Um Spencer Smith's at 4:30 on Friday.
There's some people that I haven't heard
of. I'm I'm really
going to have a fun time cuz I only have
to speak once each night. So the rest of
the time I can
go check out shows, meet people. We're
going to have a booth, but I it's just
going to be free stuff. So I don't have
to like sit there and watch the booth. I
can just leave the free books or
whatever and and you guys can get those.
Uh I'll be speaking on the left stage at
6:30
on Saturday.
Yeah, I can't wait. Look at all these
speakers, man. It's going to be awesome.
Brad's going to be there.
He's going to have his booklets and
things and
it's going to be awesome, man.
Yeah, we're going to be It's going to be
fun. Absolutely.
>> together.
That's right.
So I wanted to invite you on because all
the time we get people in here talking
about the Book of Enoch. And the Book of
Enoch, if you turn to any King James
Bible or something, you're not going to
see it in the Bible, but a lot of people
consider it biblical canon. They say it
was removed from the Bible, that it was
originally in there,
like in the Ethiopian Bible. Um My
friend Jasmine in here, she said, "I do
believe First Enoch is scripture for it
aligns with the 66 and gives some
insight on information we get on canon,
but more detailed."
So these are the types of things I hear
all the time, too. I I actually hear a
lot of people say, "Well, you know,
definitely First Enoch. Not sure about
Second and Third, but but First Enoch,
that's like
a lot of people really accept that as
solid. This was supposed to be in the
Bible, was removed at some point. Uh
Satan doesn't want us to know about it.
You know, there's something in there
that maybe Satan's trying to keep us
from knowing or understanding and that
the Book of Enoch really shines light on
it."
And then some people have they believe
in Jubilees and things like that, too,
but we're going to focus on Enoch right
now because
there's a lot in Enoch that
will
um kind of make people believe things
that maybe other Christians don't
believe when it comes to like certain
scriptures and things like that. So
you know, any any um
book that can cause you to think
differently than
I'm going to watch what I say because we
think totally different than the
majority of Christianity. I know this.
Like I'm
I am not on par with like
mainstream Christianity by any means. So
But what you did a show on this
just the other night and I was like,
"Dude, we need to talk about that cuz
this always comes up." And so I want to
I want to dig into this, see what you
have to say about it, what your research
has shown, and and bounce off you. Greg
Hall says flat Earth.
That's something that I think's
interesting because
we do talk about biblical cosmology on
this channel. I believe in it. And but
just because
something, you know, just because an old
book
will mention things that were understood
at during that time period doesn't mean
that that it's all it's all truth, you
know. 99% truth is not truth and we have
to be very careful from of that because
Satan loves to twist truth.
I mean he he rarely ever just comes out
with an outward lie. He's like in the
garden saying, "Did not God say could
eat of every tree?"
Well, yeah, but don't leave off the last
part. Not this tree, right? So
you know, you have to have 100% truth or
you will be very deceived, especially in
these last days.
Yeah, I I believe that 100%. Yeah, and
uh the Book of Enoch does Does it talk
about the flat Earth in the Book of
Enoch?
Just just so we're clear. Yeah, it um it
talks about some some things that kind
of um
go with the model. So
I I just to clarify, I read audiobook. I
listened to the Book of Enoch in 2012
and at that time I was I was getting
into everything in 2012. God opened my
eyes to New World Order, symbols
everywhere,
secret messages in
all the movies, you know, all this
stuff.
And so I started really getting hungry
for like truth, like digging into
conspiracy rabbit holes and everything
that I never looked into before because
I never My mind didn't work that way. I
didn't think that there was big
conspiracies and stuff.
And so I read the Book of Enoch or
listened to the Book of Enoch and at the
time some of the things I believed
uh that I was learning from
preachers like Chuck Missler,
um you know, he was That was the first
time I ever heard about the fallen
angels
giving marriage unto human women was
from Chuck Missler and I was like,
"Whoa, this is crazy." And then I read
the book, you know, heard the Book of
Enoch and it mentions that. Um flat
Earth stuff though,
from what I have heard because I haven't
really like studied it out from the Book
of Enoch, um it talks about how like the
sun will come out of its portal or
something and make a circuit or
something. So anytime you hear about
the sun is actually moving over the
Earth,
that's not a heliocentric globe model.
That's
cuz the heliocentric is that the Helios,
the god Helios or the sun, is the center
of the universe and it's a thousand
times bigger than Earth and all that
stuff.
That's why I believe it, you know,
that's not why I believe, but that's one
reason that really to me makes it like,
"Yeah, this is all about sun worship,
Sunday, heliocentric."
All that kind of stuff.
Now, I really appreciate Mikey's channel
cuz he really dives into the stuff that
that I don't. I'm I'm I'm more
mainstream. He's He's more of He's going
to look into
>> Mainstream.
a lot of this stuff. Yeah, you know, I
don't believe in flat Earth and all that
stuff, but it's okay. I mean
>> That doesn't mean you're mainstream,
dude.
You're talking about some hard-hitting
current event, present truth,
spiritualism in the last days that so
many people aren't talking about and
need to talk about.
>> it's like it's all on the mainstream
media. All this stuff I talk about like
it's we're on we're on ABC News, CNN,
and all this stuff. So I'm pulling all
this stuff going, "Okay, what Well,
okay, this is this is my channel because
I I want to be make sure that people
differentiate that I'm what I'm trying
to do is say, "Hey, let's follow the
progression of events that are happening
in our current life that people are
pushing and the lie that it's pushing in
the mainstream." Not not that I am 100%
um
not
believing that there is something else
going on outside of the mainstream. I
definitely do. I think there is a
progression of events that's happening
that's not being talked about. But But
um yeah, very interesting to see
everything that's going on right now. It
is, dude. Like
I it's
There was a time in my life when I would
hear Revelation and I didn't really
understand all the symbology of it and
stuff and I was like, "Yeah, there's no
way this is happening in my lifetime,
man." Like
seven-headed beast and all this stuff,
you know, it was just like this is some
like I believed it was all like
genetically modified. I was like, "Yeah,
man, scientists Like I was getting into
the conspiracy stuff and I was like,
yeah, scientists, they're trying to
bring back dinosaurs. They're trying to
do like Jurassic Park, find the DNA and
bring back these beasts and then yeah,
they could make a seven-headed beast."
And to me all that stuff was like, man,
I believe the Bible's true. I look at
prophecy like it's really going to
happen.
And I don't I don't doubt that Satan
would do something like that, but the
Bible actually tells us what all the
symbols in Revelation mean. Every vision
that God ever gave man was symbolic.
Skinny cows eating fat cows was about a
famine coming. Uh
a woman standing on the moon clothed
with the sun, that's not literal.
A harlot drinking blood riding a
seven-headed dragon. It actually says
that the seven heads represent seven
mountains, and that the waters you saw
the harlot on represent many peoples,
and that the stars represent angels, and
the lampstands represent churches. Like
it's constantly telling you this means
this.
In the book of Daniel it says the beast
that you saw represent kingdoms. The
horn represent kings and kingdoms. So
it's all symbolic, but
I do believe that Satan will manifest
those things just to throw people off,
you know.
Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. I mean, he could
make a whole uh we we could go off on
all kinds of rabbit trails here. Oh,
yeah.
>> But uh
I'm thinking about I mean, there there
there could be a false rapture as far as
that goes. I mean, that's what the UFO
thing is all about. I was taken up in a
ship, you know. Right.
>> And and so anything could happen. And so
we we need to be on our guard to know
and test the spirits when when things
happen, but I like what Jasmine just
said. She said, I did not grow up in
church or its doctrine, so I'm like a
clean slate in this area. That's really
the best place to be, man. I wish
as as bad as it is to say, I wish people
didn't grow up in church because
I would like I know a testimony, Doug
Batchelor, this guy,
he has a book called the richest
caveman.
He was searching for truth. His parents
were rich. His dad owned jet lines, and
his mom was a movie star. And he's like,
I don't want nothing to do with that
life. I'm going to I'm going to try to
find the truth. He became like a monk.
He He joined the Hare Krishna and all
this stuff. And then he became a naked
caveman for weeks.
>> button. For real. Yeah. I mean, naked
caveman. And when he was in there
he was just looking for a spiritual
journey or something like, I just want
to know what truth is or whatever.
And when he was in there, he said,
whoever was there before me left a
Bible. I'd never read a Bible in my
life. And as a naked caveman, I started
reading this Bible.
And it was a clean slate. You know, I
don't believe I don't believe if if
anybody erase their mind from what
religion has taught them, and they just
read the Bible, you'd never walk away
saying, oh,
I need to start going to church on
Sunday. You're like, no, the fourth
commandment says the Sabbath day. You'd
never be like, oh, when we die, we go
straight to heaven or hell. No, it says
that the dead in Christ will rise first.
The
when he sounds the trumpet that the dead
are going to rise out of the dust of the
earth. Like there's so many things that
are so clear in the word of God.
But we've been indoctrinated from the
church, sadly enough, that when we come
across these verses, we just think, oh,
well, you know, second death must mean
eternal torment in hell, you know. It's
like
What What do we get this from?
But yeah, we can share your screen cuz
it looks like Joe Rogan's set here. Is
she Is this chick talking about Enoch?
So this is really interesting me. This
is kind of what began the whole thing
because I I was looking at I was
watching Anna Paulina Luna, which is the
representative for Florida in the uh in
the government. She kind of does the
checks and balances for for Florida
itself.
Uh
representing Florida. And she was tasked
to look into this uh strange stuff that
was happening. She was very skeptical
about it, but she said her and the
Tennessee representative, Tim Burchett,
I think his name is. Mhm. Uh I got to
check on that. But what was really
interesting is she came back, she says,
yeah, there is something else going on
here. This is very unusual that we're
seeing things. And so this is even
though it's on Joe Rogan, Joe Rogan I
think is the new mainstream. I I I call
old mainstream legacy media. But this is
the new mainstream cuz the people if you
want to know more without a bias, you go
to these three-hour podcasts that
actually give the truth about then you
can listen to specific people that you
want to know more about. And so this was
one I wanted to know more about was what
Anna Paulina Luna actually thought after
interviewing all of our govern-
government officials on this. What is
this is a
So this is what was interesting about
it. This is what she said. Okay. Do you
think that it's possible that these are
US vehicles that are top secret? I
definitely think that there's a level of
advanced technology that the US
government has, and I think that that
that tech can be housed within the
defense contractor realm, realm, and of
course some information's going to be
classified, but I can also tell you, and
this might sound crazy, but based on our
investigations and stuff that we've
seen, okay, there is definitely
something that I think would rival what
we know currently with physics, and a
tech that potentially is out there that
we don't have the ability to reproduce
because it would basically be like
dropping a cell phone cell phone, right,
off back during the time of maybe
cavemen. So like we just don't have the
tech to develop it yet.
All right. So what she Is that Isn't
that weird? So I I think she like a
Christian?
She is a Christian. She's going to say
that here. She She grew up Catholic
though, but I don't consider Honestly, I
don't consider Catholics Christians.
They believe Catholicism is
the pagan Babylonian system just veiled
in a new disguise. I mean, the the pope
still wears the fish head hat and
everything. I mean, you look at If
you've never heard that before, just
look up
Babylonian
religion, and look up Right. Catholicism
now, and they're identical.
Yeah. And And it's veiled in this
Christian terminology where you still
worship the saints, which are actually
former
pagan gods and and all this other stuff,
but
um But she she is
She's fascinated by this cuz she says,
look, um the government has some
technology, and it's not from earth is
what she's saying. And that's what I've
I've discovered by interviewing all
these people. But she goes on to say
that their
their religion
has come out to be about the book of
Enoch. And And the the government inside
the secret bowels of these these
government officials believe that the uh
the
the book of Enoch is significant. And so
I thought I'd dig into the book of Enoch
and and really discover what is the
religion behind the book of Enoch
and and things like that. I think the
next one I want to show is is third one.
So I'm going to bring that one up. But
Any comments before I do that?
Uh no, I just thought it was interesting
cuz I thought she was a Christian from
what I've seen when she did some of the
So I I don't know if you really made it
clear who she is. She's at these US
congressional hearings when all these
military guys are talking about UFOs and
stuff, right? Mhm.
>> And she starts questioning asking them
similar things like, do you think these
could be something
I don't know if she says angels, but she
says like, some are good, some are bad.
They're not You're saying they're not
alien, they're interdimensional, stuff
like that. So I I thought she was a
Christian, and
it's strange for a Christian to talk
about the cave the time of the cavemen.
Right.
I mean, did Adam and Eve dwell in caves
and say unga bunga and
Uh man, it's
really sad where Christianity is right
now.
It is. It is. And And And before the
flood, I think we were very
technologically advanced, but there
there there's a chance that after flood,
you know, Noah and his Noah's ark and
his his rest of his family probably
lived in a cave. I mean, it was it was
hard times.
Mhm.
>> But who knows? I mean, it it it's it's
fascinating to see what's going on right
now
with all this stuff. Yeah.
Um Oh, I did want to say one thing, too.
There's some people in here saying like,
oh, I don't I don't trust Joe Rogan and
stuff.
What's interesting, what I like about
Joe Rogan, he's not a Christian at all.
And when he first really started, he was
really, you know, got the third eye on
his forehead and cussing every other I
mean, he he might still be like that,
but
what I like about Joe Rogan is he's
open-minded. He's open-minded, and he's
a true seeker.
And
you know, he got he got banned from
Spotify or something because he had a
guest on talking about the COVID shot.
And he got banned from a lot of
platforms just because of that. And he
said, he went live on his phone and
said, look, man,
I'm a true interviewer. I'm a true
journalist. Like I will have anyone on
my show to talk about anything, even if
I don't agree with it. I'll have them on
my show because that's what true
interviewing and
journalism is about. It's about hearing
all sides. And he said, that's what I
do. So just because I have somebody that
shares an opinion, even if I don't
believe in it, like how are you going to
take me down for freedom of speech for
somebody sharing their point of view or
whatever.
So he's open-minded, and lately he has
actually had
uh it
It seems like multiple Christians on cuz
I don't ever watch this stuff,
but I see shorts come up, and I keep
seeing these people that he's
interviewing talking about the Bible.
Mhm. Have you seen that?
>> Yeah.
I have. Yeah, I have. In fact, she
actually does some uh pretty pretty hard
uh push for believing in in the Bible,
too, which I was really appreciative of.
Yeah. I don't remember which clip that
that was, but um
we can roll down the same these same
clips. There are some clips that I
didn't get to because I
uh I got cut off, and I was worried that
the whole whole episode would be
deleted, but I figured out how to get
around it, not illegally, but because I
can appeal it. And so uh we can we can
continue and see those other clips that
I missed on this program, too, if you
you but
um I thought we we'd specifically talk
about Enoch, and number four is where
they really get into it. They really
start talking about Enoch, this fourth
clip here.
So, I'll roll this if you don't you
don't want to. Yeah, go for it.
Here we go.
Yeah, so what I want to bring it back to
evidence. You said that you've seen
evidence. Like what kind of evidence
have you seen?
I have seen photos. I have seen um What
have you seen photos of?
So, I was in a skiff, and I can't
discuss all that was in a skiff, but
what I can tell you is based on the
photos that I've seen, I'm very
confident that there's things out there
that have not been created by mankind.
Have not been created by mankind. This
is actually not the clip I was going to
show you, but that goes along with the
first clip. I'm going to skip to the
second one to really talk about Enoch
here.
Say again?
Oh, I just said, okay.
Yeah. What would be the rationale for
keeping a photograph of a known ab-
absolute not of this world craft from
the American people or from the world?
Why why would anybody think that that
would be the smart thing to do is to
limit the access of that information to
a very small amount of people? I think
that part of the fear is is that you
have advisors that think that, you know,
um
the American people or humanity might
not be able to handle it. Right, there's
this like Mhm. protective complex, but
then also too, I think when you are
talking about these things,
for a lot of people, I think that it
kind of can rock your world a little bit
in regards to where you stand in a faith
perspective, and then also too,
um an aspect of well, how do you even
begin to explain it? And all I'm going
to say is, look, um and we can go into
some of the books that were removed from
what we know as the modern-day Bible,
but I read through the Book of Enoch
multiple times.
And
I'm not saying that these things are
angels, okay? That's that's not at all
what I'm saying, but what I am saying is
that
depending on where you are in regards to
your whole perspective on whether or not
God exists. Like I believe in God, I'm a
Christian.
Um
there has to have been and there's
admissions that there was other
creations that God made, but that we
were the most prized creation. And so, I
think that this can open up a bigger
topic of discussion. What I will say is
that what's been interesting is and I've
had a a mass array of people that have
come in, right? Like we have people that
come in that claim that you can use this
ability to basically dog whistle these
things in from a like a psychic ability.
>> Yeah, I've heard people say that. I'm
positive.
They They They They That's the first
time they alluded to the idea of using
the Book of Enoch to really pull this
stuff out, and she specifically says
they took it out of the Bible when the
Bible was being put together in I don't
know, what was it? 400, 200
uh
AD.
Yeah, I'm not a Bible historian. I don't
I'm really bad with history. I always
hated history until kind of recently.
Um I'm trying to figure out where she's
going with that with the whole Enoch
part, but
just in case our audience here doesn't
know our stance on this,
me and Brad both on Strange Normal and
right here on Can of Truth
have a lot of videos talking about
aliens and what's going on with this
whole UFO thing.
And I totally believed in aliens my
whole life, and even when I became a
Christian at 21, I started believing the
ancient aliens theory where,
you know, Moses was led out of the
wilderness by a beam of light from a
UFO, and that Ezekiel was seeing a wheel
within a wheel with lights all over, he
was just describing a UFO, and
chariots of fire and all that stuff.
It wasn't until 2012 that God opened my
eyes that this is a demonic deception.
Demons are creating a mythology about
themselves pretending to be visitants
from far distant galaxies, and they've
been given this lie throughout history
to mankind in different forms. It was,
you know, the um
the demigods or the Anunnaki or Ra or
whoever it is. It's always these
different gods throughout history you
see from different cultures, Babylon,
Egypt, all that.
And so, for us,
it's the alien grays that fly around in
UFOs.
And it's just a new disguise, you know,
Satan was a serpent in the garden. He's
a shapeshifter. He's He can He has many
disguises. He can transform himself into
an angel of light, you know, the Bible
says this.
And we believe that it's uh
for a huge deception to deceive the
entire world into siding with demons in
a battle against the second coming of
Christ. Meaning,
humanity is not going to side with
demons. We're just
If the demons really come down looking
like horns and, you know, that's that
whole thing, that whole character of the
devil is not even true. Satan created a
character of himself that he keeps
pushing out there that he's scary and he
has horns and goat legs and all that
stuff,
so that when he appears as an angel of
light or visitants from far distant
galaxies or whatever,
that you'll think, well, this can't be
the devil because he doesn't look scary.
I'm not I don't have fear. I'm not
you know,
he doesn't have to bring fear.
Mhm. He can make you feel feelings of
love and euphoria, and that's why the
new agers are into what they're into
because they talk to ascended masters,
and they meditate, and that's the best
feeling they've had in their whole life,
and they're in the best shape and the
best health, and it's all about love and
light, right? So, Satan can do that.
And so, what we believe is that
soon, I believe very soon, this year, I
believe that this year will be
disclosure, official disclosure. They've
already been given soft disclosure over
the over the
last couple years,
that they're going to say, "Look, we
can't hide it anymore.
Something big is happening. These beings
have been among us for thousands of
years. They've never hurt us. They're
here to protect us and help us.
And if we don't side with them in this
battle, we're not we're not going to
survive because a evil alien invader is
coming to take over our world."
And so, humanity is going to side with
aliens,
you know, which are actually demons,
in a battle against Christ, who we will
all be deceived in the thinking is uh
evil alien invader.
Yeah. Yeah, the Bible says there's going
to be a huge deception, and uh and it's
going to be very very big. And and it
also uh talks in Revelation 16 about how
there were these spirits
uh of these these three frogs that go
out to the kings of the earth and to the
whole world to ready them for the battle
of the great day of God Almighty. And
these three spirits the Bible identifies
not as frogs. It It says that they are
spirits of devils. And so, you have
these spirits of devils that are going
out and whispering in the ears and
telling everybody, "Well, what is that?"
So, if that's Bible prophecy, what is
going on here? Well, this spiritualism
that comes out has got to be something
that science itself
will accept. Because if they all of a
sudden spirits start appearing to
people, everyone's going to believe that
God is real and the Bible is real, and
look,
it must be true. But in order for us to
counter that, then in order for the
devil to counter that, he has created
this this group that only believes in
evolution, that will only believe what
they see with their eyes and believe
what they touch. And it has to be done
with their senses, right? So,
all of a sudden they start to see with
their eyes and and believe what they
touch because they are seeing something
else, and they're going to name it
extraterrestrial. Right. It's going to
be demons. And so, this whole demonic
presence, or sometimes called the
externalization of the hierarchy of of
demonic entities, is going to be a real
thing. That is the new strange normal
that's going to happen soon.
Yep.
This verse on screen um the verse prior
to it talks about three unclean spirits
like frogs, you know, um
these alien grays, if you could choose
anything
in natural in nature to compare these
things to, I I would say frogs.
And it says that they're unclean spirits
that are going forth unto the kings of
the earth. So, we're talking about the
presidents, the kings, the elite, unto
the kings of the earth and to the whole
world to gather them
in the battle of the great day of God
Almighty. So, if we are Bible-believing
Christians, and we truly believe that
Jesus is coming soon,
the Bible tells us that Satan is going
to make war against the second coming of
Christ. He's going to deceive humanity
through miracles. Says right here,
"Working miracles." How many people are
going to fall for that? They're going to
say, "Wait a minute, Satan can't do
miracles. He can only kill seek kill and
destroy, right?"
No, he can do miracles. Yeah, have you
ever heard of Reiki? Do you believe in
that? You think that these new agers
that are doing Reiki, that that's of
God? No, Satan is behind this stuff.
Satan can bring affliction on people who
have opened up doors in their life in
one way or another, whether that was,
you know, movies you're not supposed to
watch or
uh dream catcher in your house, idols,
or fornication, or whatever.
When you open yourself up to demonic
possession and oppression,
he can put an ailment on you, and you
can deal with that for years and years
and years, and then suddenly this
beautiful angel comes along and heals
you,
removes that ailment, and now you
believe that you are healed, and you
think there's no way that this is the
devil. That's what Chris Bledsoe is
saying right now. Another self-professed
Christian says that he had an encounter
with UFOs and alien grays and all that,
and he said they healed him of a
lifelong disease he had, um Crohn's.
And he said, "No, he was his son was
terrified saying these things are
demons. He's like, "No, son, they're
they're good angels. They healed me."
No other discernment, no other testing
of the spirits, just they healed me.
That's what we're going to be facing in
the last days. Spiritual beings doing
lying signs and wonders, miracle-working
demons.
And so many people, if they don't
understand how Satan works, they're
going to fall for this deception.
100% 100% All right, this next clip is
where they get into really Joe Rogan
really starts to stress
what happened to the Book of Enoch. Why
if the government believes this stuff,
why why isn't it in the Bible anymore?
Watch this. But then again, you get into
this aspect of, you know, why is it that
you also have this aspect of, you know,
a certain religion that has been very
controlled and I think ruled out in a
certain aspect. And, you know, when you
have certain books that are removed
because they don't think that people
should have access to this information
or know it,
you know, why remove a book from a
Bible, right?
>> Was Did Wes Huff did Did he touch on
that?
Did he talk about that? Or did Are there
people that don't believe the Book of
Enoch was really a part of the Bible?
Yeah.
I don't remember how he discussed the
missing books. Yeah, he I think we
brought it up, but I don't remember how
I That's the guy to talk to. Yeah, so
what from
>> That's the guy to talk to about it. You
know what I mean? Because you have to
really understand the history of the
Bible to to be able to figure out
what you like what's legitimate, what's
not, why they put it into the New
Testament. I had some very erroneous
ideas about it until I talked to
intelligent people that really really
know the history of it. And it's it's
very strange stuff. Well, so from from
what I gather, and by the way, I'm not a
theologian in any capacity, but just
from my personal opinion on this. So,
you have the Ethiopian Orthodox text,
which has I think 88 books in the of the
Bible in total. But in the Ethiopian
Orthodox text, it's basically kind of
like a a mainline OG version of the
Bible. And then sometime in the 4th
century, there was actually a group that
came together and they removed certain
books. And
the story goes that Revelations actually
had replaced Enoch. And so it's
interesting because when you're looking
kind of full circle on, you know, you
hear the stuff that some of these people
are talking about, and then you see and
you read the Book of Enoch, which is a
wild read, okay? And then you look at
kind of what our modern-day description
is of what angels and entities are
versus what Enoch was seeing and
reporting in his language and ability at
the time. I just I think that there's a
lot that
brings you to then ask the question,
well, why would they remove this
information if it's truly, you know,
written in in part of the oldest Bible
in the world, why would they then take
it out and and water it down? And I'm
not saying that you can't find God
through the new Bible, right? Like
everyone's on their own spiritual
journey, and I think everyone can pray
and you can ask access God. But
I just find that very interesting. And
All right, we're going to pause it
there.
This This is interesting to me because
she really gets into this. And what
really bothers me is that they say, and
I have not been able to prove this. In
fact, I've proved counter to this, that
the Book of Enoch was in the ancient
Ethiopian Bible. I I think it had You
don't think that's true?
I don't think so. No, cuz it the the the
first
That's what I'm saying, too. I just
said, "When was the Book of Enoch
discovered?" It says the Book of Enoch
was rediscovered in the 18th century and
also found among the Dead Sea Scrolls in
1947. While it was excluded from the
Jewish and Christian Bible canons, it
was preserved in its entirety by the
Ethiopian Orthodox. But
what what's so special about the
Ethiopian Bible? I mean, is it like the
perfect
version or something?
No, I Do you know from what I
understand, there wasn't even but just
snippets of of of this
Enoch text inside there. I don't even
think it contained the whole thing cuz
it says that um uh let's see, where is
it? The The full Book of Enoch was
discovered in
Abyssinia in 1773 by the Scottish
explorer James Bruce. This discovery
revealed the text which is a collection
of ancient Jewish apocalyptic writings.
Bruce also brought back to to Europe a
select collection of Ethiopian
manuscripts. Along with Ethiopian
manuscript were three copies of the Book
of Enoch. Bruce presented the find
find in specially prepared copies of the
book to King Louis the XV in Paris. And
three manuscripts brought by Bruce mark
the beginning of the modern study of the
Book of Enoch. So, we we we didn't even
even realize or think about this book as
something that was scriptural cuz it was
not scripture. And And I'll I'll show
you exactly why it's not scripture in a
moment here.
Are we still on?
On, yeah.
Okay, good.
I thought we we left there for a second.
No, we got 88 people watching.
Yeah. No, this is this is really
fascinating stuff because let me bring
up
a And this is where I why I got into
this. I'm going to bring up some
text here
that really nails it home on why in the
world
it was
not included.
And while I find that,
where did it go?
Things working hard tonight. It closed.
All right, I'm going to try to bring it
back up.
There it is.
Okay.
The screen.
Or not. There we go. Okay.
Can you see this?
Let me see. Yes. Well, it's kind of
small. Can you zoom in some?
That's as far as I can get.
Oh.
Okay. It's kind of small. I wish I could
do some on my end
to make it bigger. Okay.
So, um Put your glasses on, yeah.
I know it.
>> I can't see it. Wow. So, um
Wait, is that something that I can pull
up?
Yeah. Yeah, I can send it to you. Yeah,
send it to me through
uh Facebook.
Facebook?
Facebook it is. And meanwhile, I'll just
keep it up right here. And I'll
pop it in here.
Let's see here. Facebook it is.
My key.
Okay, it says it's coming through. Do do
do. Okay.
Got it.
All right, switcheroo
here.
All right, what is this? It looks cool.
Yeah, so this is this is really very
interesting. I I put this together.
Uh
I had it somewhere on my channel, Windy.
She did an extensive study on the Book
of Enoch. And we did a a podcast about
this. So, I took her study and then I
also took um
the actual Book of Enoch from
bookofenoch.org.
I put it in the chat GPT. I fed it some
information. I said, "Let's label out in
a chart what it is about the Bible
that's different in the Book of Enoch.
How is it so Why is there so much
controversy over this?"
And so, um
these are the things that came out. It
came up nine verses that primarily are
are very interesting
uh
for people. And so, I put those in five
different pages here.
Let's just read them. This is
summary of the This is summary over here
and the two different verses that really
contradict each other from this stuff. I
do want to say this is a great way to
use AI. Like there's people that think
that
AI is just straight up like a demonic
entity.
If you Yeah, if you start talking to AI
and saying like, "Hey,
I want to talk to the dead." Or "Are you
a demon?" Or something crazy like that.
Satan can use that tool. He can use a a
piece of cardboard and a piece of
plastic oracle, right? So, he can use
technology or whatever.
But when you tell AI, which is literally
just it's artificial intelligence. If
you tell it,
uh hey, I have this book and I have this
book. Are there anything in these two
books that are the same? Are there
anything in these two books that are
different? Contradict Man, this is a
great This is a great tool because we do
not have the capacity. Like it would
take us a lifetime to probably read the
Bible versus Enoch compared side by
side. But we live in the last days. Uh
we live in where knowledge is running to
and fro. People are I mean, knowledge is
increasing. People are running to and
fro like
we are not going to have an excuse when
Christ returns. We all have the world's
library in our pocket.
A a book One book used to cost a
thousand dollars. You had to be
literally wealthy beyond belief to have
a book. And now we can look up anything.
And with AI, it's just getting even
better to the point where
when Jesus returns and somebody says,
"Well, I I didn't know." He's going to
say, "Did you try?" Did you ask Chat GPT
like is anything in the Bible come true?
Or is prophecy real? Like there's so
many just simple questions for any truth
seeker. Of course, fact-check
everything. Maybe AI is giving you wrong
information. If you're truly seeking for
truth, you can find it with these tools,
man. I love what you did here.
100% 100% So, the the Book of Enoch
attributes the primary source of sin and
corruption on Earth to the actions of
fallen angels who taught forbidden
knowledge to humanity. This is
interesting. The Bible in contrast
states that sin entered the world
through disobedience
of one man, Adam. So, it says in the
Book of Enoch 6:2, 8:1, 10:8, "And the
angels, the son of heaven, saw them and
they desired them." That was just
talking about something that we're going
to get into a little bit later. But and
as
taught them so it it as Azazel is
actually a as they they say in the Book
of Enoch is a fallen angel. Taught and
or the watchers as they call them taught
men to make swords and daggers and the
whole earth
has been ruined by teaching of the works
of Azazel. Azazel Azazel As I understand
this writing. It's also the name of the
scapegoat.
Oh, yeah. That's right.
But but Romans 5:12 says, "Therefore
just as sin entered the world through
one man and the death through sin and in
this way death came to all people
because all sinned." And that's not all.
I mean, we got we got so many more. If
that's not that's not a really hard a
home run, but we're going to we're going
to really Yeah, I'm I'm kind of curious
what what was the contradiction here
exactly?
Yeah, so it says that
that sin came in and they taught men to
to do all kinds of sins.
They create daggers, create swords,
create war basically and ruin the earth
because of that. He did. Yeah, I mean
I'm sure
you know, satanic entities did that, but
it goes on further and says that
absolutely they they brought in sin,
but the Bible says that it was brought
in through originally through Adam. And
so I think that's interesting that it
says it that Romans says it came in
through Adam, but
it says that it originally came in
through through fallen angels that
brought it. And so in other words, they
didn't it wasn't humanity that sinned
originally. It was fallen angels that
brought in war that brought in the
originals. Yeah. So that's interesting.
>> I I could I'll play devil's advocate on
that one. I could see, you know, Lucifer
was the first sinner.
Mhm.
You know, nobody even the watching like
the holy angels had no clue what was
Imagine being in a perfect world where
you're with God the creator and there's
like
the
the idea of sin can't even enter your
mind. Like a lie, what is that? I never
What is that? What is a lie? It's not
the truth. What is not the truth? I
mean, everything's a truth, you know?
Imagine that and then, you know,
deception, pride, they're just like,
"What is this
strange feeling coming over us because
of Lucifer? What's up with him? Like
we've never felt this
dark feeling, you know?"
Mhm. So yeah,
yeah.
Let's see what else.
>> Yeah, not a home run, but I I think
we're going to find that as we go on
with this other other stuff is it's
going to become very obvious that there
is something wrong with the Book of
Enoch. Mhm. Enoch expressly
explicitly describes angels desiring
human women, marrying them and fathering
children. Oh, I don't need to scroll
down.
Oh, yeah, scroll down a little bit.
>> Oh, okay.
So one. No, I I I just went to the
second one.
So it should be yeah, should be there.
There. Yeah, it should be we're talking
about that one I think right there.
Matthew 22:30 and
I was like, "How are you controlling my
screen?"
I forgot I wasn't even paying attention
when you were highlighting stuff, but
yeah, it's like a Google Doc or
something, huh?
This is awesome way to do this.
Wait, I can I can do that? Oh, wow.
That's cool.
>> yeah.
Neat. Um and so and so Jesus' statement
in Matthew suggests that angels are not
sexual beings and do not engage in
marriage, which contradicts the idea of
them procreating with humans. And so
where is that? Well, it says Matthew
22:30. It says, "For in the resurrection
they neither marry nor given in
marriage, but are like angels in
heaven." Now, I've had people say,
"Well, come on. It doesn't explicitly
say they don't have genitals." But you
think about it. Um Yeah. Why would a
God's creation have a genitals if they
could not procreate? Right. Okay, then
there's someone will say, "Well well, no
no. Doesn't say they don't procreate."
Well, okay. They don't marry. So if you
don't marry, there would be no reason
for genitals.
>> It'd be fornication. If you if you
procreate procreated without marriage,
that's fornication.
Yeah. Yeah, it's that's a sin. So why in
the world would you have genitals if you
can't use them? You You know what I
mean? The Bible says we battle not
against flesh and blood, so
and it's talking about fallen angels.
Battle not against flesh and blood, but
principalities against the rulers of
darkness of this world. So they're not
flesh and blood. How do you how do you
mate with human women? They are all
male. I've never once heard of a female
Bible a female angel in the Bible. Now,
you might find it in some other book and
that's another red flag. But it always
says like, you know, two men in white
apparel asked, "What are you gazing at?"
or whatever. It described them as like
white men in white apparel
or you know, in the context of he.
So they're all men. They're all
immortal. If they're holy angels,
they're not dying. They're not they they
got right to the tree of life. So
there's no need to populate immortality.
There's eventually you'd overpopulate,
right?
So Mhm. Yeah, there's no need for them
to have sperm bearing testicles. I don't
think God would
create that.
I think Eve was the first
female ever created as far as I know
from the Bible. I mean
The Bible doesn't really say any other
any other females besides what the ones
on earth, but
I'm not opposed to believing the other
worlds Well, we'll get into that later.
But but I I at the same time I don't I
have to bring it back to the Bible and
say everything we have to believe has to
come from from the Bible. And so we're
going to decide whether the Book of
Enoch really is a part of the Bible or
not.
We should we should look at this comment
cuz it says in Matthew it speaks
directly that the women cover their
faces to not tempt the angels. Enoch is
also directly quoted in Jude.
Mhm. Matthew says that Cover their
cover their hair.
To not tempt the angels?
To not tempt the angels. It doesn't say
what they're tempting them for though.
And so it doesn't say, "Oh, they're
tempting them because their hair is
sexual." Doesn't say that. It it it is
weird.
It is a weird text,
but
Yeah, um let me see if I can find that
real quick. Um
Bible verse hair tempt angels
And it says that Enoch is also quoted in
Jude. I've I've heard this stuff, too.
Yeah, 1 Corinthians 11:10. For for this
reason that a woman ought to have
authority over her own head because of
the angels. That's very vague. What in
the world does that mean, you know?
Because of the angels.
Well, it doesn't say that angels
sexually like their hair. That's I I
want to be That's what it doesn't say.
What verse is it?
It's 1 Corinthians 11:10.
Oh, let me open a new one.
That's Well, I read the NIV. Let me read
the KJV real quick. For this cause
No, no. 1 Corinthians 11:10.
>> Oh, somebody just said it was in
Matthew. 1
Corinthians What was it? Sorry.
1 Corinthians 11:10. Yeah. 11:10
>> ought the women have power on her head
because of the angels.
For this cause ought the woman to have
power
on her head because of the angels.
I'm not seeing that as anything to do
with it. I'm not
That's wild. That's a wild thing to say.
Sometimes Paul isn't very clear on what
he's talking about in the
>> So let's look at the context. For a man
indeed ought not to cover his head for
as much as he is the image of the glory
of God. Uh-oh, I don't know. See, yeah,
some people say if I'm wearing a hat,
I'm covering my head or something. But
the woman is the glory of the man. For
the man is not of the woman, but the
woman is of the man. Neither was the man
created for the woman, but the woman for
the man.
Okay, that's the context. For this cause
ought the woman to have power on her
head because of the angels.
Uh
That context had nothing to do with
seducing angelic beings.
Nevertheless, neither is the man without
the woman, neither the woman without the
man in the Lord.
For as the woman is of the man, even so
is the man also. Okay, so
Yeah, I'm not seeing anything
remotely about seducing angels because
of your hair or your face or whatever.
So Unless there's another verse unless
we missed that.
But but Enoch goes in and it says that
and the angels the son of sons of heaven
saw them and desired them, I guess the
women. And they said to one another,
"Come and let us for
choose for ourselves wives from the
children of men and let us beget
ourselves children." And it's So This is
partly in the Bible, but it doesn't say
that the angels did this in the Bible.
Right.
>> took wives for themselves and everyone
chose for himself one each and they
began to go into them and were
promiscuous with them. See, I think a
lot of people take this Enoch and go,
"Oh, that's the missing stuff right
there." Because it hooks into into into
sexuality and it leaves a mark on your
brain going, "Oh, well, that's what's
going on here." But the Bible doesn't
say that. It doesn't talk about how that
that that this uh
this group of people was angels at all.
It calls them the giants in the land.
Yep.
So I do think it's interesting it says
that the angels don't marry and the big
argument I always hear from people that
believe Enoch is saying
well, the good angels don't give in
marriage. It doesn't say that. It says
we become like the angels
who don't give into marriage. Now,
somebody did point out it says, "But are
like the angels of God in heaven."
Like why would I specify that it was
specific angels?
Because
when we enter heaven when we after the
resurrection it's talking about after
the resurrection. After the resurrection
there's only going to be good angels
left. So the context is like after the
resurrection, we're going to become like
the angels. We don't give in marriage.
Um again
no flesh and blood.
I don't think that they could
insert angelic nonhuman like nonflesh
and blood sperm into a woman and
actually impregnate her. Everything else
in nature can't interbreed. You can't
breed a snake with a rabbit or
something. It doesn't work. It just
doesn't happen.
So, why would it happen?
Why would God allow it to happen? Is
really the point. Why would God allow
something like this to happen?
And so,
are you going to get into where this
comes from in Genesis 6?
Yeah, I I can. I can. I I was uh um
absolutely, we can do that, but I wasn't
planning to. I was going to go on to the
next uh
>> people are going to be really confused
if we don't cover it cuz um
it sounds a lot like that and people are
going to be like, "Pff, you never read
Genesis 6. What are you talking about,
you crazies?"
So, remember
the the Bible is not
it's not like chapters and verses and
you're supposed to read the Bible as a
whole. It is 66 books, like scrolls that
were
you know, retrieved from 1,200 years of
a span time and
over 40 authors. Like, that's what makes
it such a miraculous book. But, now that
it's been compiled together, it is one
whole book. We're not supposed to say,
"Oh, that's the Old Testament. That's
not for us. That's the New Testament."
or whatever.
It's all one book.
And there was no punctuation, there was
no chapters, there were no verses. So,
it's like a run-on sentence and you kind
of have to figure out like what what
these people are saying. And it says,
"And it came to pass when men began to
multiply on the face of the earth and
daughters were born unto them." So, what
are we talking about? Men giving birth
to daughters. And or that the sons of
God saw the daughters of men that they
were fair and they took them wives of
all what they chose. So, we got this
term sons of God. That's the confusion
right here. Sons of God
saw daughters of men.
And the Lord said, "My spirit shall not
always strive with man, for that he also
is flesh. Yet, his days shall be 120
years." So,
right now, it's talking about women and
God's saying, "My spirit shall not
always strive with man." I know it's
talking about mankind or whatever, but
he's upset with men. He's upset with
humankind. Why is he not upset with the
angels that took the wives?
This is really like I'm I'm just now
seeing this for the first time. Like,
I've read this a bunch of times, but
this is making sense to me right now.
Like, why would God be upset with the
women who were basically raped by these
angels if that's the case? They they
took wives. It doesn't say like the
women were seduced by these angelic
beings.
And then it says,
"There were giants in the earth in those
days and also after that, when the sons
of God came into the daughters of men
and they bare children to them and they
became the same or they the same became
mighty men which were
uh of old, men of renown." So,
basically, when people read this, they
say, "Look, when the sons of God, who
are angels, went into the daughters of
men, they bore giants." But, that's not
what it says. It just says, "There were
giants also in those days."
You know, it's like it's just saying,
"Here's another attribute of what those
days were like. There were giants." It
doesn't say they were evil, it doesn't
say anything, it just says there were
giants. You know, I There's
there's some reasons to believe that
maybe Adam and Eve were giants.
You know, these It doesn't always mean
that they were evil. Um
I don't know where I don't know how much
truth there is to the
Adam and Eve being giants, but I know
that um
what is it called? The Quran says like
E- Adam was like uh 16 ft tall or
something. But, anyway,
>> Yeah, like they will actually lift up a
robe with a crane and show you like how
tall he was or whatever. But, anyway,
don't be You guys are going to be
quoting me saying Mikey believes in the
Quran. I don't. I'm just saying.
Anyway,
so, we we're hearing this. Sons of God
took wives and God is mad at the men
that humankind. Why is he mad at humans
for something that the
you know, that something angels did if
that's the if that's the case. Then it
says, "There were giants in the earth in
those days and also after that, when the
sons of God came into the daughters of
men and they bare children, the same
became mighty men, men of old, men of
renown." That doesn't say that the that
the
offspring of these people were
uh hybrids. It says that they were
mighty men, men of old, men of renown.
You'll see that phrase in all kinds of
other people. Um
What's the one like
I don't know, different kings and stuff.
So,
so you know where people get this from?
I'm I'm I'm going to I'm sure this is in
the chat right now. So, I want to I want
to flush this out real quick. Bring it
back to my screen if you don't mind real
quick.
>> Okay. I'm going to show the people some.
Oh, it's not going to show my screen.
Oh, that's right. I got to bring my
screen all the way over here in order to
show it. Ah. Well, we have to we have to
explain who the sons of God are or else
people are going to be lost. Is that
what you're doing?
>> Yeah, that's what I'm doing. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
>> So, Is it going to be small?
Uh it is, isn't it?
Send me that link.
>> to I'm trying to What what what is that?
BibleHub or something? Yeah, BibleHub.
>> Oh, perfect. You're good.
Okay. So, so this is interesting cuz uh
Nephilim in here is is where people
really get stuck because in the in the
KJV, which is what we're reading from,
it says the giants. But, but right here
in
a lot of other translations, all of a
sudden, boom, it becomes Nephilim. And
and you got to wonder what is that. So,
people go, "Okay, I got to go to the I
got to go to the the Strong's Lexicon
and find out what is Nephilim." and they
get the idea, this is a lie, that that
the the Nephilim means the fallen ones.
But, if you go and look at the
definition yourself, I'm going to bring
this up real quick. Um maximize this.
Look at what it says here. This is the
Strong's definition. It says, "Giants,
Nephilim, Strong's definitions." It
says, "Nephiyl uh from this area,
properly, the feller." What is a feller?
Well, it's
a man.
>> A tyrant.
And then giant. Most bullies are large,
you know, like
or else they're not going to be a good
bully, you know.
Little scrawny guy trying to bully you
around.
It's not It's not a fallen angel.
>> That's interesting.
>> mean fallen angel. I've never actually
seen
the definite I I've just always heard,
"Yeah, giants. It's actually Nephilim
and Nephilim's a hybrid." I've never
actually looked up what uh
the Strong says about the Nephilim, but
um
yeah.
Basically, are you going to get into all
the times that the Bible uses sons of
God?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Yeah, it's going to clarify it right up.
Bring up this real quick.
>> I mean, there's still going to be people
that aren't going to believe it, but at
least, you know, we're showing I can't
get any any bigger than that. Um Oh,
send me that or
Didn't you have it in BibleHub or
something?
Cuz I I have I have this pulled up. Let
me see if I
>> I tried to look up every time that the
verse every time that the phrase sons of
God was used.
And it says right here in the New
Testament, the term
takes on a more spiritual or relational
meaning. John 1:12 states, "But, to all
who did receive him, to those who
believed in his name, he gave the right
to become the children of God." Or some
translations say sons of God. Here, sons
of God refers to believers who had
accepted Jesus Christ and are thus
adopted into God's family.
So, over and over we see this. The
Apostle Paul further elaborates on this
concept saying, "For all who were led by
the spirit are of God are sons of God."
So, we keep seeing that this term sons
of God simply means God's people.
And so, who are the daughters of men?
Well, that phrase actually only shows up
in Genesis 6, but if you search the
phrase, I wish I had a way to search
phrases up from the Bible. If you search
the phrase um sons of men, it's always
in the context of the wicked, the
pagans. Every time. So, the daughters of
men are simply
women who aren't aren't believers.
They're not God's people. They're pagan
women. And sons of God, which are
actually good.
So, Satan loves to twist everything to
the opposite, man. You know, when when
it when it comes to the rapture topic,
he's taught people that you don't want
to be left behind. You don't want to be
left behind. But, in reality, you want
to be left behind or because the
opposite is destroyed. Well,
to be
I can't remember how it is. Um one was
taken and the other was left. To be
taken means destroyed.
So, you don't want to be taken. Yeah,
you want to be left behind. So, Satan
always twists it. Even even with the
prophecy uh in Daniel
Daniel 9:27, I think. It's talking about
um he shall make a covenant with many in
the midst of the week. He shall make it
or in the midst of the week he was cut
off, but not for himself. And they're
like, "Yep, that's Jesus. He fulfilled
it perfectly." And then the next line
says, "And he will make a covenant with
many." Christ did that, the new
covenant. "And will cause the sacrifices
to cease." He did, when he died on the
cross, the sacrificial system ceased,
veil was torn from top to bottom. And
they say, "That's the Antichrist."
They say that he who is going to make a
new covenant, he Okay, so he must be
making a deal with Israel. And if he's
going to cause the sacrifices to cease,
that must mean that he's going to build
a new temple. And they get this whole
idea like there's going to be a third
like that the third temple prophecy is
is like a third temple being built is
somehow fulfilling prophecy and it has
to do with the Antichrist, when it's not
even in the Bible.
The prophecy is about Jesus Christ and
they've turned it into the Antichrist.
So Satan loves to flip the model and so
here it's the same thing. It's like the
sons of God, which are God's people, but
Satan's flipped it. No, they're evil
angels.
The Nephilim. Yeah, it's it's it's wild
what this is saying. So it's so somebody
Somebody did ask us to look up another
verse.
Genesis
19:5-8.
I'm curious cuz I I never heard Genesis
19 come up in this topic.
Genesis 19:5-8.
Oh, what is this?
Okay.
Genesis
5-8
So it says,
"And they called unto Lot and said unto
him, 'Where are the men which came into
the this night?'" Okay, so this is
talking about Sodom and Gomorrah when
they the men wanted to have sex with the
angels. Mhm.
So yeah, just because men just because
gay men see beautiful angelic beings and
want to have sex with them doesn't mean
that
angels have sperm-bearing testicles. I'm
not sure.
>> Right.
They were, you know,
this is where it's strange because it
says that they were not flesh and blood.
We wrestle not against flesh and blood.
But they often took the form of men
who could eat
and, you know, do whatever humans could
do.
But I don't
I don't think that just like just
because they can take the form of men
mean that they have sperm
that can actually like procreate with
humans.
>> Yeah.
Uh
Um did you have something you wanted to
show on your screen?
No, no, I was it. Uh just I just uh
behold the manner John 1:3. I'm I forget
what verse you read, but I had behold
what manner of love the Father has
bestowed upon us that we should be
called sons of God. Yeah. Well, who's
called sons of God? We are. So yeah, I
just want to make sure that the audience
knows what we believe about the
Nephilim, the sons of God who came into
the daughters of men
is over and over the Bible tells us do
not be unequally yoked. Why? Because it
always leads to disaster. Look at
Solomon. He fell into paganism. Look at
Samson. He
you know, he fell for that chick and she
was trying to kill him and he ended up
getting his eyes gouged out and all that
stuff.
Uh the Israelites,
how did the enemy trip them up? They
couldn't they couldn't win the wars and
stuff, so they said, "You know what?
We'll get the pagan women to have a big
party and seduce them over there and
we'll win that way."
So over and over do not marry pagan
women. Do not marry don't be unequally
yoked. And what happened in those in
these days of Noah in these last days
and stuff that was going on back then?
It was
there was intermingling. There was
God's people and pagan people mingling
together and what did it cause? Much
evil in the world because
unfortunately, you usually don't win
over the pagan.
Usually the pagan wins you over. That's
what happens over and over. We see it.
And so Genesis 6 is saying, "Look, this
is what was going on. This is why the
world was evil." The whole world was
evil because of this mingling of my
people and the pagan people and it just
they got watered down and lukewarm and
eventually
just straight evil to where the
their hearts were only evil continually.
Yeah.
Yeah, 100%.
100%. Is there a next thing the next
line here?
Yeah, yeah. Go scroll all the way down.
We're going to go from uh almost. Go to
the one that says I'm I'm not going to
skip all of this stuff. I don't want to.
>> I'll highlight yeah, it's a good idea
actually. I'm moving it over just a
second.
See.
Why isn't it working? There we go.
All right, there we go. Let's go on this
one. Um Origins
This is this is interesting. Enoch
teaches that the disembodied spirits of
the Nephilim, the giants, became evil
spirits or demons that roam the earth.
The Bible identifies Nephilim as a
physical being, hero of old, men of
renown, but never states that spirits
become demons.
The Bible origin of demons is associated
with Satan and angels. See, that's
crazy. If you only read Genesis 6, you
would read it and say,
"Oh, sons of God, that's God's people.
Daughters of men, that's the opposite.
That's like the sons of men. They were
not not God's people."
And then we would see that they gave
birth to these
men of renown, men of old. You wouldn't
think of that and say, "Oh,
wait a minute. That's a that's a fallen
angel hybrid."
But when you read the book of Enoch with
it and use that as your guide and you
say, "Wait a minute. According to the
book of Enoch, this phrase means a
demonic hybrid. Wow, now I get it."
And and really it's like you're reading
Satan's commentary for the Bible.
How to interpret the Bible according to
Satan.
Yeah, and that's what appears that he's
doing. Go go to the very last one on
this.
I think this is interesting, too.
It says um the very last point on the on
the script. All the way down.
I have Yeah, yeah, you got it right
here. Uh
It says the book of Enoch culminates
by identifying Enoch himself as a
messianic messianic or the Messiah, son
of man.
So uh who was born to righteousness.
This I this directly contradicts the New
Testament where Jesus Christ is
exclusively identified as the divine son
of man and the sole path to God. So it
says
uh Enoch says, "And the angel came to me
and greeted me with his voice saying,
'You are the son of man who was born to
righteousness and righteousness remains
over you.'" So So this is interesting
because there there's more context to
this that I couldn't bring out, but all
throughout like chapter 71 and and
further back, it talks about how Enoch
himself he was the Messiah for the
angels and the he wanted to bring the
angels back to God and and uh and and
look, John 14:6 says Jesus answered, "I
am the way, the truth, and the life. No
one comes to the Father except through
me." So if there was anybody that was
going to be a Messiah, it was going to
be
Christ preincarnate before he came to
earth, right? And we don't have any
indication in the Bible about that. So
it really you really need two witnesses
to really say that the book of Enoch is
is it's just to say that it is is truth
because it's not it's not true.
>> Yeah.
That's that's the key. Line upon line,
precept upon precept, here a little,
there a little by the mouth of two or
three witnesses. When you start going
building doctrines off one verse, man,
you can believe all kinds of stuff. And
that's where so much of this stuff, the
rapture, the what happens when you die,
hell, all this stuff is based on like
one or two verses out of context,
misunderstood
in the Bible that
um Yeah.
If you guys have not seen
on our channel here,
um
I don't know what that's pulling up. Uh
I don't
>> media outlets and scientific community
>> I am not trying to play that. Um
So if you guys have not seen
on our channel what really happens when
you die,
I encourage you guys so much to watch
this um
because it helps you understand the
truth
about what happens when you die. You
know, the Bible talks about do not do
not communicate with the dead because
the dead know nothing. Because when
you're communicating with the dead, it's
called necromancy. It's sorcery. It is
communication with demons in disguise.
The dead are dead. I'm I'm hoping that
these verses will pull up and show
um
all the verses that talk about what
happens when you die. It's it's always
talking about that the
Look at this. "And many of those who
sleep in the dust of the earth shall
awake, some to everlasting life, some to
shame and everlasting contempt." So when
you're dead, you're asleep. And where
are you asleep? At the in the dust of
the earth. And what's happening? You
will awake.
But we're told, "No, you're alive.
You're awake in heaven. You're enjoying
bliss or you're down there in eternal
torment until the judgment." Which makes
no sense. Why would you receive your
reward before the judgment comes? You
spend a thousand years in hell, then
Jesus comes, you come out of hell to
face judgment to get thrown right back
in hell. Makes no sense at all.
And people say, "No, you're getting it
wrong, man. You go to Sheol." And that's
like this waiting place where you But
that's the that's the doctrine of
purgatory. It's not biblical.
And the Bible says you sleep and you
will awake when Jesus comes.
Um
So it talks about the dead in Christ
shall rise first. What is this saying?
Blessed is the Blessed are those who
die.
Um
Yeah, see when when Lazarus was dead for
four days,
the Jesus was saying, "Oh, he's he's
asleep." And they say, "Oh, well, if
he's asleep, he'll rest and do well,
right?" And it says, "Now Jesus had
spoken of his death."
Uh
They said he might rest. Oh, I'm I'm
trying to remember. There's a verse
where his sister, Lazarus's sister,
says,
"Oh, Jesus, if you were here, he'd you
know, he'd be alive." And and Jesus
said, "Oh, he'll rise again."
And she goes, "Oh, I know he'll rise in
the last day." Like she knew exactly
what happens when you die. She's like,
"Oh, I know I know he's going to rise in
the last day and he's like, "No, like
you're going to see a miracle."
So, I don't have time to go into the
whole topic of what happens when you
die,
but please check out what really happens
when you die. You can see it's over an
hour long. All verses back-to-back
showing that when you're dead, you're
dead.
Why is that important? Because the Book
of Enoch actually teaches
that um
Enoch saw the disembodied spirit of
Abel. That goes against everything that
we understand about what happens when
you die.
What a person even is.
A person is
dust of the earth, which is his body,
and the spirit of God, which is our
breath.
I don't know where that comes from. It
comes from God. I don't know why it
keeps me alive, but that's the that's
the energy source of God. It's his
breath. That's That's the breath of
life. So, that's spirit. So, you got
body and spirit. You put them together
and you get a living soul. That's what
the Bible says.
And so, this whole idea that there's a
disembodied spirit, oh, I got a ghost in
me that comes out when I die and it's
alive and conscious,
it's pagan. That's It's what the serpent
said in the garden, you will not surely
die. Don't believe that. You're going to
go on living and every everybody but
Christians are supposed to believe that.
Christians aren't supposed to believe
that, but everyone else is believing,
oh, reincarnation or oh, you when you
die, your energy still goes on living,
bro. It's like goes to the universe.
It's always
people outside of Christianity that
believe that when you die, you're not
really dead.
Yeah. That's not what the Bible says.
Yeah.
You know, uh our hope is in the
resurrection, the Bible says.
That's what Paul said, that my hope is
in the resurrection.
Did you have a other
slides to show?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Oh. Yeah. One more thing.
So, we we looked at what, you know, the
sons of God, this whole concept of
angels breeding with women.
It's It goes against the Bible.
Um the Enoch saw the disembodied spirit
of Abel. That's not true. Abel's dead,
waiting for the resurrection.
And Enoch was taken by an angel flying
over what appeared to be hell, like a
fiery place of torment. We just did a
video on that. Did a video just the
other day on um
on hell, the truth about hell according
to the Bible.
Like, your chart your church has a lied
to you about hell,
whether knowingly or unknowingly.
Hell is the destruction of the wicked at
the end of time, at the judgment day.
It's the lake of fire. It happens on the
face of the earth. Like, man, I I wish
everyone would would watch this video
because it says
in Ezekiel that Satan will be turned to
ashes on the face of the earth and be no
more.
You will walk upon his ashes. Yeah.
>> Yeah. We're going to the wicked are
going to be the ashes under the soles of
our feet. There'll be neither root nor
branch. It It says John 3:16 says you're
either going to have eternal life or
perish. Those are your choices.
We We are born into sin.
We are going to die. It's
a positive fact, 100%. Every single
living person will die, but God wants to
give you eternal life, the gift. If you
don't take the the gift of everlasting
life, you're going to die. Die. But at
judgment, you're going to be cast into
the lake of fire, which is the second
death, which is an eternal punishment,
which is a everlasting destruction
because Jesus said, don't fear him who
can not kill or don't fear not him who
can kill the body, but fear him who can
destroy
both body and soul in hell. Over and
over,
God's saying, if you don't take my free
gift, you'll be destroyed, not ever
you're going to be tormented forever and
ever and because the the wicked don't
have immortality. The wicked don't have
the gift of everlasting life and the
wicked don't have right to the tree of
life. So, how can they burn forever and
ever and ever if they don't have
immortality, everlasting life, or right
to the tree of life? That's the only way
you can live forever.
So,
the fact that Enoch had this vision of
hell,
or what appeared to be uh this pagan
view of hell,
is also not biblical. So, that's
That's three main points that have made
me know the Book of Enoch is not canon.
It contradicts the Bible. Yes, there's
some truth in it, like biblical
cosmology and I believe the fallen
angels did teach men how to make weapons
and wear makeup and root cutting, which
was hallucinogenic drugs and stuff.
I don't see it in the Bible, but it
makes sense that men
wickedness comes from the inspiration of
evil angels. I believe that.
Yes. Sorry, I was I was paying attention
to what you were saying.
Take it away, brother.
>> watching. Sorry, man. I don't I'm not
trying to like I I just didn't know if
any of that stuff will come up. And I
want
>> Yeah. No.
>> I want to give people solid answers why
I don't believe the Book of Enoch
because
the truth that I believe,
it's it's like heresy to say you don't
believe in Enoch.
I mean, if you if you believe in
biblical cosmology and
really, that's that's the big one, I
guess.
If you believe in biblical cosmology,
like people are just like, the Book of
Enoch.
And if you don't believe it, they're
just
ready to give you two thumbs down on
your YouTube channel while you're live
streaming.
Well, any interaction is good
interaction.
>> That's right.
>> That's what I say.
If you guys agree, give a thumbs up. You
disagree, give a thumbs down. I want to
get take a poll here.
And it helps the algorithm. Thanks,
guys.
Absolute. Absolute. So,
I'm the rest of the the the the clips I
have were just him talking about how
he's amazed that that they're taking it
out of the Bible and and how
the the man is is causing all this grief
for us and he's hiding stuff from hiding
the the hidden truth from us and you
know, he's just ranting about this
stuff. Then he actually goes into the
nuttiness of the Book of Enoch and and
how it's it's probably not uh probably
not in there and and they kind of do
that at the end, but it really wasn't a
hard push. So,
the my concern was, hey,
this big deception that's coming in at
the end, this this big Revelation 16
thing, is primarily a lot of people
believing that the Book of Enoch uh is
is showing that these things are coming
and they they uh it's it's obvious that
they are are man that
is here to procreate and create human
hybrids of some kind. And I think that's
that's nuts. And so, yeah, Satan can can
cause anything, but he's he's
Book of Enoch is not proving
is not not helpful at all. You know
what's another great point that just hit
me when you said that?
I don't think Satan can create life.
Yeah. So, how can Satan breed with
somebody and literally do what God
created
God created this act of man and woman
because really,
God said it's not good that man should
be alone. That's what he said. Because
man only has one attribute of God. Not
one, but we have one half of the
attributes of God. Like,
you know, we're smart, we can uh
we're strong, we can build, we can plant
gardens and all this stuff,
but we can't we don't have like that
nurturing spirit, that sweet spirit. We
don't We can't nurse a baby with our own
body, feed a baby with our body. So,
together, when you have a man and a
woman who come together as one, you're
really the closest to the character of
God as you could ever be because you
have both attributes. You got the
you know, the attributes of man, the
attributes of woman. And then, what can
you do? You can create life, just like
God did. You can't do it on your own.
You can't do it with two men.
Oh, man, that's why Satan is all about
this gay junk, dude, because it's like
taking God's perfect design, like, hey,
I'm going to show you my character.
He always uses illustrations of uh he's
our husband, coming to take his bride.
Like, the illustration of marriage is
the perfect illustration of God. And he
says, look, you're you're alone if
you're man and should not be alone. When
you come together and become as one, now
you're the perfect illustration of me
and guess what? You can create life.
But if you put man and man together, no
life. Woman and woman together, no life.
And so, Spirit being and human? No life.
>> Satan can't produce. He can't create
life unless it's like artificially in a
lab only using elements that God has
already created, but he cannot himself
out of his own testes create life.
If he has them. Yeah. And Did you
already mention this? This this is a
This is a This is an interesting point,
too. Even if they had genitalia, even if
they were all male, he's not the same
kind. Right.
>> you so, you can't take a giraffe and a
hippopotamus and create a
giraffapotamus. That's right.
>> So, if you can't create a a
a spirit and a human and create
a spirit human no life.
>> A human.
So, Look at all these humans.
>> So, it's not possible. It's just not
possible.
Yeah, dude. I
This is really like the deepest
conversation I've had on this topic.
I've talked about it a lot, but there's
been a couple new things here, new new
ideas that have been coming out in this
conversation. I like it a lot.
Yeah. Yeah.
That's all I got. I mean, there's some
more clips we can watch that are just
interesting, but out of the stuff I want
to actually show, that's the this is
like mind-blowing. This is This is it.
Does this go with Enoch?
Something to do with Enoch?
Yeah, it's just him saying the same
thing over and over again. Show, where
is Enoch? Why is I I take that stuff out
of Enoch? And he's just very focused on
Enoch. You know what I thought was
interesting about this conversation with
Joe Rogan is that
he was more skeptical of Enoch than she
was.
She's like, "You know, I'm a Christian
and I believe in cavemen. I believe in
the book of Enoch." And he's like,
"You know,
you can't always trust books that have
supposedly been removed and stuff." You
know, he was like using critical
thinking. He was using discernment. I'm
like, "Whoa."
And then he started talking about that
guy West Huff who he had on his show.
I think that's awesome. I've never
watched anything by West Huff. I know
he's
probably the biggest Christian YouTuber
on YouTube.
And
uh it's really awesome that he was able
to get on Joe Rogan.
That he was able to plant some seeds.
You know, I I didn't even watch the
whole thing, but I've I've heard other
people say that
it seemed like Joe Rogan was really open
to the stuff that he was saying. It
started making him think of the Bible
more as something that could be valid
instead of just like, "Ah, this is just
ignorant book." or whatever.
Yeah. And I think that's where Joe's at
right now. He's like, "You know, I'm
still searching, but I'm not I'm not
totally
antagonistic towards the Bible anymore."
Which is cool.
Small steps, man. I actually I I pray
for him, man, sometimes. I actually pray
to be on his show. So, if you guys want
to pray for that, I want to
uh
share with his audience the Gnosticism
that's in all the movies and stuff. I
think that would blow people's minds.
There
There's a pattern of Gnosticism in the
majority of movies. And if that's the
case, why?
Why is there such an attack on God? You
don't see a pattern of people attacking
Buddhism or uh Muslims or anything,
really.
But you always see this attack on Oh,
and we just talked about this on episode
like two episodes ago.
That
um
what is it called? Anti-Semitism.
Anti-Semitism is against the law.
It's like illegal. I pulled it up on a
government website. It's against the law
to discriminate or say something
against Jews cuz it's called
Anti-Semitism. But Marilyn Manson
Yeah, Marilyn Manson can repeatedly tear
up the Bible on stage in front of
thousands of people.
So, how come Christianity's not
protected as a a holy religion? Or why
is it not hate speech or hate crime to
bash Christians? It is against Muslims
or Jewish people.
Homosexuals. You know,
all these communities are protected and
yet the the irony of it is
is that as a white heterosexual male
we're called privileged.
White privilege. Like I'm I'm not
protected. I don't have There's not laws
protecting me.
Wow, man.
Yeah, there's something going on.
There's something going on. There
There's actually a lot of things I want
to look into. Well, I just think it's
Satan's world.
Why is everybody protected but God's
people?
Right.
It to me it proves all the more that God
is real and that there's a spiritual war
we're living in, you know? And I I hope
that Joe Rogan will be able to see that.
Absolute. Absolute. I didn't mean to cut
you off. What were you saying?
No, that's that's it. That's all I want
to say. I'm just reading the chat now. I
I I Yeah, I bet there's some good stuff
in
I'm I'm everyone's um
focused on what's going on here. I'm
really glad we're we're talking about
this. I think this is an important
topic. The book of Enoch is is really
really um
a deep subject and I think it needs
needs more study to to really
hash out everything that's that is a
problem here cuz a lot of people are
taking it and going, "Look, this is more
Bible than the Bible." And it's not.
It's true. Actually have heard that, you
know, people they don't say it that way.
They won't say the book of Enoch's
greater than the Bible, but if you
teach a truth from the Bible that
contradicts Enoch, they can't believe
it. They're like,
"No, that can't be true because Enoch
says, you know."
And that's that's a problem.
And so some people say, "Well, you're
narrow-minded. You stick to the 66 books
that had these books removed and that's
why you're so ignorant and narrow-minded
because you can't see the truth of
that's in these other books." I've
already exposed myself to those books. I
actually believed it when I first heard
it.
But my views over time have changed. The
The more I studied, the more I couldn't
believe the things I used to believe.
And so I thought it made perfect sense
that angels mated with women and created
these demonic hybrids and that's why the
world was so wicked that God had to
flood it. He had to get rid of that
manipulated, tainted gene pool, the DNA.
Mhm. But then I saw Jesus say
that angels don't give in marriage. I
was like, "Wait a minute. Now I got to
rethink this." And so I started looking
deeper. What is What are Who are the
sons of God? Every time it mentions it's
it's God's people.
Um
and that that really changed my whole my
whole beliefs on that.
Mhm.
You got any final thoughts, man?
No, just saying that um you know, we
need to stay in the book. Stay focused
on the book, only the book. And if we
deter from the book, then we will
very much mess ourselves up. And so
that's
that's my final words. Stay in the book.
You guys don't forget to check out
Strange Normal. So, I put in the search
bar Strange Normal and subscribe to his
channel, man. He's got 20,000
subscribers for a reason. He's talking
about some
heavy-hitting stuff. Got your
finger on the pulse of what's going on
in the
in the culture according to prophecy. I
mean, man, I don't even know what this
is. Raelianism. Man, I got to
I got to catch up, man.
I've missed some of these shows, dude.
I'm looking at them like, "Whoa, I got
to see some of this stuff."
And
you guys are going to really enjoy his
content. We do a lot of crossover stuff.
I'm glad to finally have you on the
channel, man. I can't believe it's taken
all this time to have you come on about
something, but this was a good topic.
So,
I'm glad we got to sit here and cut it
up. I want to know in the chat, did
anybody
hear anything new? Did they
believe anything different? Or
you guys let us know in the comments
section.
I'm seeing some It looks like some good
positive content in here. There's still
people that are
believing it, of course, but
Mhm. That's what we do, man. We just
want to present both sides of the case
so that you can make up your own
decision. That's what I believe.
Amen. Looking at all the evidence and
going with where the weight of evidence
uh measures out. And if if there's still
like a couple things, like one or two
scriptures that seem contradictory,
really study those things out. Look at
the Greek and the Hebrew. Look at the
context. Context is king.
And so when you're looking at any topic,
what happens when you die? It's like
this 60 verses say that you are asleep,
but then there's like, "Oh, what about
thief on the cross? What about rich man
and Lazarus?" And these things. Look
into those things. Figure out why those
two or three verses seem to contradict
the majority of what the Bible says.
Bible doesn't contradict itself.
It's It's a lot of it comes from the
fact that we're reading an English
translation of Greek and Hebrew and we
don't always use the best translation
the best words.
Mhm.
Yeah, man. Thanks for being on here,
dude. And you guys check out Strange
Normal.
And can't wait to do another show with
you, man. I'm going to sign us off real
quick.
Thank you guys so much for being here.
This was an awesome conversation. If you
guys learned something new, let us know
in the comments section. I'm going to
hear what you guys have to say. If you
didn't agree with us, let us know why.
Tell us down there. If you were blessed
by this, please give a thumbs up or give
a thumbs down. Either way helps the
channel. If you want to support this
channel, you can do so by going to
candidtruth.org.
We got many ways to give on there.
Remember, we are a donator a donor-based
ministry. We can only do this with your
support. We don't get a check outside of
this at all. I don't have time to do a
job and the channel. So, we thank you
guys so much. We see you guys. We love
you guys. For those of you who are who
are supporting this channel um on a
monthly basis, we cannot thank you
enough. We love you. And if you guys
like t-shirts, check out our merch
section on our channel. We got some cool
t-shirts that talk about it's cool to
use your brain or the truth will set you
free or love is kind and many others.
And a simple, easy, free way to support
this channel, click a thumbs up, share
it with your family and friends, and
subscribe so you don't miss another
episode of Candid Truth. And we'll see
you next time on Candid Truth.